because they're being on keeping on
Smitty making their way up still a knife
but only a half came back is that one
game out of sixth place that's correct
they are definitely have a chance
getting out of FIFA don't think they'll
catch the fourth place team but would
that be unbelievable the Lakers end up
five or six after all they went through
throughout this season I don't think we
can talk enough about how good DeAngelo
Russell was Brendan 28 points on 10 of
17 from the field he hit five of the
eight threes he attempted but we haven't
seen him in six games listen for him to
come back this first game and just look
like he hasn't missed a beat you know
sometimes you come back and you're a
little winded you're a little rusty Dilo
got right back out there he got right to
it right away quick and early in this
game started off with quick 12.7 assist
and never look back whether it was
Diamond teammates making incredible
dribble moves off the bounce like you
see right here like D'Angelo Russell had
another ball handler and and shot maker
to this team and when you envision what
this is going to look like with LeBron
James back and A.D roaming around the
paint it's going to be a lot it's going
to be very scary for everybody in the
Western Conference especially with the
fact that these Lakers are playing some
of the best defense in the league at
this present moment this team right now
is built to make a run I know it seems
weird to look at a team that's in ninth
place and say oh man that team might
make a championship run the Lakers are
good enough to do that I'm not saying
that they will but they are good enough
if things break the right way or if they
get to the 6th seed they are good enough
to come out of the West from that spot
I'm glad you mentioned not only
D'Angelo's scoring but his facilitating
that offense as well those nine assists
and the way that he's spacing the floor
looks a lot more like the Lakers team
that we all thought could contend to
this I think when you have a point guard
that ability to be able to knock down A3
also opens up everything is also opens
up how the big will play pick and roll
defensively and now if you step up he is
crafting up and he can find people who
has great vision if you have some guys
knocking down threes that'll definitely
help Delo he'll get some plays like this
where he gets some easy layups and
disenvision running pick and roll with
LeBron James getting down here that's
the one thing as LeBron James as a
screen Setter but then he can knock down
threes he's played off the basketball a
lot in Minnesota with Anthony Edwards
right now and I think also they added
some length DeAngelo has some length at
the guard position Vanderbilt LeBron A.D
they have some sizes hashimura as well
yes yeah